This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, talk about the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are going to be talking about the psychology of revenge, what some of us might think of as an ugly feeling, but what is actually one of the most complex, layered human emotions that we can have. Some of my absolute favorite movies and books are written about this concept. Think like Kill Bill or Promising Young Women or Taken. And I find our human need for like an eye for an eye so interesting.
It's one of those universal human impulses that we all get, whether or not we've acted on it, whether or not we've acknowledged it or not. You know, if only I could make my ex hurt the way that they hurt me, if only I could get back at that friend who betrayed me or that person who cut me off on the road, sometimes it almost feels satisfying to either enact revenge or to daydream about all the ways we could. Is that a good thing? Why do we feel such like a weird pleasure around hurting someone who hurt us. Here's the paradox as well. Revenge promises satisfaction, but more often than not, you might not know this, you probably do, but it actually leaves us feeling emptier than before.
It might feel good initially. Is it really worth the cost? And how do you navigate feeling such a messy, bitter feeling that maybe goes up against your more inherent desire to be a good person? why is the drive towards revenge so strong? When shall we act on it? When should we avoid it? These are all the kind of questions that we're going to be answering today's episode, as well as looking at some listener stories of people who have sought revenge and what the consequences were. There is so much pettiness, so much drama in this episode, so many good stories, and also so much psychology. It's almost unbelievable. So without further additional further attention, do let's get into the psychology of revenge. I feel like the idea of revenge is almost romantic at this
point. It's like this driving force for so many dramatic moments. Some people would even call them poetic moments. So what exactly is it about revenge that makes it so powerful and so hard to resist? To understand revenge, we really have to start at the origin feeling, at what is going on before we even decide to get back at someone. When someone wrongs us, that's the beginning of this process, our brain obviously interprets it as a threat, not just to our safety, but also to more high-level cognitive values. So things like social status, it's a threat to social status, it's a threat to our sense of fairness, it's also a threat to our identity.
Now, when you have a healthy ego, there is this like invisible protective boundary or shield around you, it kind of represents like a limit of what you will and won't tolerate. And when someone oversteps that boundary when the shield is penetrated, that's when something pretty ancient in us is triggered. Now, some people's, you know, boundary shield is quite small and close to them, and some people's is quite wide. Regardless, it is actually completely subjective, but studies in the field of neuroscience have shown that when someone crosses that boundary, there is a the specific area in our brain called the dorsal striatum that immediately lights up. Interestingly, it's also the same area that lights up when we eat chocolate, when we win money,
when we receive praise from somebody. In other words, the anticipation of revenge after someone has hurt us, harmed us, betrayed us, literally does feel initially quite pleasurable. This, from an evolutionary perspective, makes a lot of sense. We are wired to respond to injustice. If we think about early groups of humans, we pretty much relied on this elusive concept of fairness to survive. Being wronged, having your resources stolen, having your reputation undermined, having your partner taken, that could and would threaten your survival. And so revenge served as a signal to others that this kind of behavior was unacceptable. So, in a way, it actually worked to reinforce social rules and to deter people or others from
betrayal or from hurting people. Basically, it's like the classic idea of punishment, punishing the offender, teaching them a lesson, restoring harmony, and also signaling to the wider group that this is not okay, but also that you are not an easy target. And this kind of reputational enforcement that you are not somebody to be messed with was really adaptive in smaller communities where reputation affected access to mates to protection to resources. So long before laws or social contracts, this instinct was really, really helpful. It's actually what psychologists would call altruistic punishment. basically, yes, the outcome of revenge might not be necessarily positive for the other person,
but it also has a greater good in that it used to maintain group cooperation and it actually used to be good for social harmony, knowing that there was this balance between giving people respect and knowing that if you overstepped your boundary, you would also receive some kind of punishment that taught you not to do that. So it is a very, very old feeling. That's what we need to understand, especially if you feel a lot of guilt around wanting to enact revenge against someone. The question that we kind of get into is, why would it therefore still be useful in modern life? You know, when we have laws and law enforcement, when we have rules, when we have a legal system, why do we still feel the feeling if technically there are other systems that are meant to, you know,
take care of that for us? the most obvious driver for revenge is this need for justice. And I know I just mentioned the legal system and law enforcement system. What if that system is broken? What if that system doesn't work in your interests? What if the thing that someone did wasn't necessarily illegal but still really hurt you deeply? Like what if it was someone who cheated or something really petty and small that you couldn't necessarily sue someone for, but which still really annoyed you and hurt you. I remember when my ex was secretly dating someone whilst we were having discussions of like, do we get back together or not?
And we were having all these talks about like, no, we definitely have a future together. Give me a second chance. And the whole time he was dating somebody else. And when I found out, I had never felt that surge of adrenaline before. that like this, to be honest, like desire to hurt him. And it honestly, like, it shocked me. Like, it made me see myself differently as an individual. This is like the classic they must pay kind of motive,
the belief that for fairness to be enacted, retribution is somewhat required. Revenge also allows us to reassert control. If we've been betrayed, humiliated, or made to feel powerless, us, like fantasizing about payback gives us a sense of agency, even if we don't do anything about it. There's this idea of like, yes, this person stepped all over me. Yes, this person hurt me. But I know I could get back at them if I wanted to. And therefore, I actually do have some level of control in this situation. So it kind of serves as this like emotional, moral, like psychological recalibration
that stops us from being additionally hurt by this idea that we are powerless to what people do to us. Many people also believe that revenge actually helps people get closure. There's this perception that if you retaliate and make someone feel the way that they made you feel, that is when you can walk away. That is when the door is closed. Unsurprisingly, maybe surprisingly, research shows that revenge actually rarely provides closure. In fact, according to research published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, those who enact or engage in revenge actually tend to ruminate even more about the
initial event, and they tend to actually feel that their negative emotions are kept alive. In comparison, people who resist revenge, even resist fantasizing about it, often recover faster emotionally from the event and from the person and the act that hurt them. Just something to keep in mind. The final driver towards revenge is just plain old impulsivity. It's like this knee-jerk reaction to feeling disarmed by someone else's action. We just have to lash out. That's a really crucial thing about revenge is that it often isn't planned.
it is so primal and emotional that it's not strategic. You just want to hurt the other person, which is why it also tends to backfire or to not feel as good as we initially think it will. This might be like the angry text that you send that you really regret later on when you know you're meant to be the person who rises above things or like the public call out on your Instagram stories.
the heat of the moment reaction. You know, I, gosh, I like remember, I remember when a group of my closest friends all went on this overseas trip together when I was 19. And they didn't tell me and they kind of asked people, other people around us not to tell me either. And I ended up finding out from someone else, what was my reaction to that? It was to post this, like, really cringe Instagram story that was like, when someone shows you who you are, like, believe them.
Like, it's so awkward to think about right now, like, that I did that. And obviously, I ended up having a conversation with them, but, like, that was my first reaction. I feel so cringe. But in the moment, like, that was the only way, the impulsive way to restore balance in that situation. So this kind of impulsive revenge is driven by the limbic system. We speak about that a lot. It's this emotional center in your brain that has evolved to keep us alive in dangerous situations by being extremely reactive. Specifically, the amygdala is the key actor here. This is the part of your brain responsible for processing fear, anger, threats, humiliation, hurt. So when we do experience those things, the amygdala fires pretty instantly and it sends signals to our body that, you know, we need to be
on high alert, we need to be doing something, we need to be acting. And when it's an emotional situation where we can't necessarily fight back or run away or freeze, we lash out, I guess we fight back psychologically and emotionally and cognitively by trying in some way to be in control of the situation, even if it ends up being kind of ridiculous. This does not necessarily help us in the modern world. It has the potential to be very destructive. The tricky thing here is that,
impulsive revenge is incredibly fleeting. Once the adrenaline fades, I promise you the satisfaction fades as well. What's left behind is often regret and shame. Studies, again, neuroscience studies have found that impulsive acts of aggression, they do produce short bursts of reward-related activity in our brains, followed by increases in negative self-referential processing. What does that mean? It's basically that like, oh crap, what have I done feeling?
They're like, what does this say about me feeling? I thought I was better than this feeling. And that feels awful. Of course, we also have planned revenge. This is the colder, more deliberate. kind that comes from higher up in the brain's hierarchy. It involves the prefrontal cortex. The prefrontal cortex and the amygdala are like the same but different. They are incredibly integral in how our brain operates, but the prefrontal cortex is all rational. It's long-term
planning, it's impulse control. You would think that it would, and it is there to kind of mediate the amygdala. But when like our instinct for revenge gets shift. it into that space, suddenly as the injustice lingers and the hot-headedness and the rage goes down, there's like this new colder dimension to how we're thinking about hurting people. We're incredibly strategic. It's not chaotic. It's, yeah, it's planned. We're thinking it through sometimes for months on end and it can feel quite cathartic, considered, soothing. one story I heard from a listener was about how she got revenge on a boss who had harassed her by slowly keeping track of receipts and like basically indications that he was stealing money
from the restaurant that she was working at. So how she did this and I'm in a paraphrase what she said, but basically she was always offering to close the tills at the end of the night. And she would count all the money and she would count all the credit card transactions and whenever it was and keep like doubles of the receipts, take photos of the receipts, take photos of her count because she knew that the boss was taking like $300 to $400 to $400 off what she had put in and off her like calculations and claiming to his boss that like, you know, they'd made less for the day. And one day she was like, I waited for six months doing this slowly and slowly because he wouldn't do it
every day. And eventually I went to, like, my boss's boss and I got him fired. See, I don't know how I feel about that. I kind of love that for her. Another more, I guess sinister story was from a listener whose partner cheated. And she did have evidence. He didn't know that she knew. But again, she stayed with him for another three months. She was like, I just went all in. I felt nothing towards him, but I, like, convinced him that I wanted to get married, that he should like propose to me and we should move in together. And then one weekend he went on like a boy's trip and she packed up half the house left over that weekend and literally had gotten a job out of state, mood states,
no contact never spoke to him again. And I was like, this is girl, this is crazy. Like, you know, you built him up and you like made him feel so in love. And then she just like cut it off and she was like, that's what he made me feel. And I was like, honestly, power to you if it made you feel better. I guess. It kind of sounds like he deserves it. But if you've never felt this way, if you've never been able to plan this, sometimes it actually does come down to our personality. For me, like my form of revenge, revenge has always been very impulsive. But, you know, in the cases where
not necessarily these cases, but people where they go like really intense on someone over something petty, there is actually something probably different about how their brain operates and about their personality that sociologists and psychologists and neuroscientists have been trying to figure out. So there's one particular social psychologist called Ian McKee at the University of Adelaide who was looking into this, I think still at this very moment. And according to him, people who are more vengeful in the planned sense tend to actually score higher on two traits. Right wing authoritarianism. Basically, they're very willing to submit to authority figures and they're willing to act aggressively in their name. And social dominance orientation. They want
their group to be at the top of the hierarchy. These individuals are motivated by power, by hierarchy, by the preservation of status. They don't want to lose face. They are much more likely to seek out planned revenge. His research also showed that these personalities tend to be less forgiving, less benevolent, and more driven by authority and tradition rather than empathy or understanding. There's also a cultural dimension to this as well, to seeking out revenge. Michelle Gelfand, another psychologist in this area, her and her colleagues found that what triggers our need for revenge actually differs across cultures. In the US, in Australia, in the UK and other individualistic societies, revenge is often fuelled by anger and the violation of personal rights,
the violation of things like property rights. Like, this is mine, it belongs to me, do not take it, you're not allowed it, and if you try, I'm a new and act. revenge on you. But in collectivist cultures, people aren't so fussed by that stuff. It's more about and more triggered by violations of duty and honor and violations against the community. Gelfin also noted that revenge can actually be more contagious in collectivist cultures as well, whereby when you harm a member of someone's in-group, so a family member or a close friend, that actually for those individuals feels more like harm to oneself than others who are living in individualistic societies. It's not just my pain, like it's our pain.
So revenge in these situations isn't about personal temperament. It's more about cultural and social belonging and maintaining the fabric of the collectivist society rather than protecting what's yours. we're going to return to this idea I mentioned before, which is that on some level, revenge is actually really satisfying. What about the costs? If you are sitting there thinking, I'm kind of tossing up what I do in this situation. Someone has hurt me. I want to act on it. Let's talk about what you should actually do. Practically, what should you do after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court, hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Revenge feels amazing. There is no other way to say it. It activates the brain's reward centers. It gives us a search of control, a search of pleasure. The hidden cost is, of course, that fades, but also that the more we plot and rehearse revenge, the more we anchor our emotional state to the person who has hurt us. The more invested and intertwined our stories become. The more we make our peace conditional on something, and what What's conditional on is their pain. And this is where this can get a little bit tricky. There's a really interesting piece of research from Iowa State,
conducted in 2022, which basically looked at 600 participants. They partnered them up for this experiment, and the researchers asked them to write just a really basic essay, and they were told that these essays would be reviewed by their partner. what was actually happening was that every single person in this study had the same partner. It was a research assistant. And that research assistant slash the research team gave every single one of these people, or at least half of these people, sorry, really bad feedback.
They were like, this is really bad, this is poorly written, this is terrible, you don't have any talent for this. And they were trying to anger the participants. So all of the participants were in this condition. All of them had the bad feedback. But then participants were then split into three different groups, the rumination group. These participants were asked to hit a punching bag whilst looking at the photo idea of their supposed partner.
A distraction group where they were shown a picture of an athlete whilst being asked to think about becoming super fit and punching the bag. And finally, a control group where participants just, were asked to sit quietly for a little while after receiving their results. What's really interesting is that the participants in the control group, the ones who are just like, sit quietly, think about the situation, they got over it faster. They showed the lowest levels of anger and aggression compared to the groups of participants
who vented their feelings in some way. Processing the pain in the pain, individually, counter to what we think and counter to what our Olympic system is going to tell us, is the best option. Even the most calculated revenge came at a psychological cost and comes at a psychological cost. It keeps you entangled with the person who hurt you. It actually prolongs your emotional dependence on them, meaning that they still have power. even in their absence.
This idea that you want to get back at them still allows them to exist within your mind. Someone described it to me as like emotional quicksand. The harder you struggle to make someone else feel what you feel, the deeper you sink into the very pain that you are trying to escape. This echoes what a lot of emotional regulation theories will tell us. When we feel anger, we reinforce its neural pathways. Every time we replay the story,
every fantasy that we have of getting even, our brain strengthens the association between pain and vengeance as the only solution. Here's also what's strange about revenge. Sometimes we do get exactly what we want it. You know, the apology never came, so we did get even. They felt the sting. The balance in theory was restored. And yet afterwards, you don't actually. You don't actually feel righteous, you don't actually feel better, sometimes we actually feel worse about ourselves. This has nothing to do with the other person. It has everything to do with us. There is this idea and psychology of effective forecasting. Essentially, it's our human tendency to mispredict or falsely predict how future events will make us feel. In the moment, we think that revenge is going to make
everything feel better, the justice will be restored, everything's going to feel great. We think it will cancel out our hurt, but we overestimate the emotional payoff and we underestimate how terrible we're actually going to feel. In particular, when we act on our desire for revenge, it actually changes how we perceive ourselves. In that instance of payback, you are no longer just the person who was wronged in this situation. You also become the person who has wronged someone else. And that moral dissonance is really uncomfortable.
because it blurs the boundary between victim and perpetrator. It splits us. That's how this is described. It splits you between the person you were before the pain, the victim, and the person who you became in response to it, not necessarily the villain, but not necessarily the victim either. This neuroscientist and experimental psychologist Molly Crockett at Princeton, she has shown that this kind of moral decision making, such as do I, seek revenge or not, feels good because it activates the reward network. It also activates the
empathy network, especially this area called the ventromedial prefrontal cortex, that almost immediately makes you see someone else's pain and feel it yourself, even if you don't like them. Every single person has the structure of their brain, whether it's as active as someone else's or not, but, you know, when you retaliate, those empathy circuits, they don't switch off. They keep processing the other person's pain. And the human brain really struggles to feel pleasure and pain at the same time, to feel empathy and pleasure at the same time. So you have this, like, really uneasy, like, juxtaposition of satisfaction and whether
you acknowledge it or not, a sense of sadness. This is part of why people often describe revenge as like leaving a bad taste. A bunch of social psychologists, one in particular called Rosen Haidt. They have written about the different domains of disgust and how, yes, you feel disgust at like, oh, this food is off, oh, like this smells bad. You also feel moral disgust. moral disgust at having gone down to someone else's level, feeling kind of dirty because of it. That's why when people say things like, I just, I can't understand how they could hurt me, can't understand how they could treat me like this, that's actually a really good thing.
Of course you can't understand why they did that to you because you're not like them at all. That's a really great thing. of course you can't empathize or try and recreate the situation that made them hurt you because you're not them, you're better than them in this situation. Like, it feels weird to say that, but you are. So should we ever take the low road over the high road? Is it ever acceptable morally to do unto others what they've done to us? Human morality has wrestled with this question for literally, like, for thousands of years.
So there's not really anything new I can bring to this conversation other than just summarize the two kind of arguments. On one hand, there's that very ancient law of retaliation. You know, it's famously captured in the Old Testament, life for life, eye for eye, tooth for tooth. In its original context, this wasn't actually meant to encourage. revenge, it was actually meant to discourage cruelty. It didn't say, you know, don't seek revenge. It was basically trying to say, like, there are boundaries around vengeance. It needs to be proportional. You can't kill someone because they stole your cow. You can't, you know, burn their house down because they knocked over your, like, carrot stand. I don't know what my analogies are,
but you know what I mean. In its early form, yeah, revenge was totally normalized, but justice in this early sense, it meant balance, it didn't mean escalation. However, as human ethics have evolved, so does our understanding of justice. More than like two millennia later, Martin Luther King Jr., he reframed that same principle when he said, the old law of eye for an eye, tooth through tooth, leaves everyone blind and toothless, right? And his point was that vengeance multiplies suffering. It doesn't actually restore harmony. It corrods it. So what's changed and how we think about doing on to others? Well, modern psychology really suggests that revenge just exists because there is a tension between two competing moral systems. We are taught that we need to seek justice. I feel like that words come up a lot. We're also taught to care about other people.
Care says we should forgive. Justice says they should get what they deserve. That is also why revenge feels so kind of delicious at times. because that moral friction is interesting and doesn't have a right answer. So it's fascinating. We go back and forth and back and forth. We don't really know which one we should do because both feel equally important. Some philosophers, for example, Emmanuel Kant, have argued that justice does actually require retribution and to maintain a moral society. We need to do that. But Canada is like a lot more humanist. traditions do say that it doesn't produce good. Like the highest moral act isn't to mirror someone else's behavior, it is to rise above it. Researchers who specifically study empathy and moral reasoning, they describe this as moral elevation. You will feel better when you witness or encourage or perform forgiveness. So if you are, you know, something to just terrible has happened to you and you want to get revenge and you want to get revenge because you think it will make you feel better, you might not like to hear it, but you will experience
more reward from not necessarily forgiving somebody, but trying to maybe understand why they did it, trying to maybe not justify it, but just trying to make peace with it without them being involved at all. Forgiveness actually gives us neurologically a deeper sense and kind of reward and sense of dignity and sense of empowerment. Doesn't mean that forgiveness is easy. Doesn't mean that it's even possible. Sometimes choosing not to retaliate isn't about moral superiority.
It's just about refusing to hand over more of your peace and power to a person who already took more of it than they deserve. So maybe the real moral question we're getting to here is whether revenge is acceptable, but whether it is useful for you? If we think about more productive options, radical empathy is like one that's probably going to come up a lot. Radical empathy is like the unconditional empathy and forgiveness that we have for other people's actions. Doesn't mean permitting them, doesn't mean letting them do it again, doesn't mean forgetting. It's just a piece that we restore within ourselves that, you know, we're not, we're going to release the pain that we feel about this. We're going to have empathy for them. It's about actually
really acknowledging like how someone else may have been hurt into their hurt, may have been harmed into harming, may have been driven to cruelty through ignorance or fear. And it is, without a doubt, I think personally, a much more freeing approach. We have seen it again with studies and with neuroimaging, like people who have this radical empathy approach are actually happier. Isn't that like the best revenge? Isn't success and happiness and peace? The best revenge of all? Probably. So maybe it's uncomfortable to hear that that might be the way to go about it. I think that this approach personally is one that it is one that I've adopted in the last year and it has made me just feel a little bit less mad about the world.
You know, I got into such a rut this year, thinking about the world as just like full of terrible people who rule our lives and do terrible things that we just have to watch and observe and that people are cruel and everybody is mad and angry all the time. It wasn't a nice place to be, but I started doing this exercise where when I felt this way, I had to think about someone who I was angered by or mad at that I was going to forgive and I was going to think positive things about. Someone in my life, in that day, in this month, that I really wanted to be angry towards who I could just in that moment symbolically forgive
and wish well. And that wasn't for them, even though, of course, in some ways it was. It was for me. People doing bad, hurtful things will have us believe that there is no good in the world, but how can that be true if we demonstrate good and if we choose love? So it actually does, I think, change how you just view the balance of good and evil in a way that's always going to mean that, I don't know, it's always going to mean that you have a more positive outlook. Obviously, not everyone deserves empathy, but this again is not about these people. This is about you. This is about you being able to be free of whatever a pain this person has caused you in one possible way. I think it's just like weird experience
that you have, which is that when you stop needing someone else to suffer in order to feel okay, like you actually really start to move on, which is again annoying and it's frustrating. I love like this idea again of like success is the best revenge or like karma will take care of it for you. I truly believe that. And the interesting thing is that like obviously I love this. science and I love the psychology. I don't have any scientific research or scientific backing to prove that karma will take care of it for me. But anecdotally, I just feel like everything kind of evens out eventually. And it just stops you from having to labor over how you're going to get them back. It just stops you from giving them more of your energy. Like, they've already done something bad to
you. That's bad enough. Don't let them then take all these precious moments that you could be spending, giving love to others or doing other things. Obviously, easier said than done. I feel like everything we talked about today is easier said than done. But I do think that it's the more peaceful approach. And I do think that like having had like real grudges like about people in the past and at times like not being able to let it go for many, many years. The best thing that I've done is to just like seriously and vigorously and aggressively and aggressively focus on myself and to just put everything into being successful, everything into being a good person so that like on the off chance they come to check in on me or they start watching or
whatever it is or, you know, they follow me on Instagram like, I don't know. on the off chance they try and slide back in like they can just see that they tried their best to like kind of bring me down and it like never worked and the thing is is that it actually doesn't matter whether they ever do notice that I'm happy or do notice that I'm successful or do notice that my life is good because when I started focusing on that stuff I just stopped caring about them completely and it was like incredibly incredibly liberating and it was just like so much better than any form of retaliation. I feel like I've done both, but silence and just like silence, no contact, completely focusing on my own lane, was the most empowering thing that I
could do. So those are my musings on revenge. That is the psychology of revenge and why we seek it, why we want it, whether it's actually worthwhile. And there's like radical empathy, success is the best revenge, carmatic kind of response to it that it's kind of a form of like acceptance therapy as well, accepting that you can't control other people, but you can control your response. Like, that's really what's empowering about it. I'm going on and on about this because I feel like I've drilled it into you by now. But I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you have made it this far, I want you to leave a little olive emoji down below to like symbolize an olive branch, symbolize forgiveness, not necessarily the olive branch that you need to extend to anybody,
but like just the symbol of what we're asking for for ourselves, forgiving ourselves, forgiving somebody else in our mind, not through actions, and just being able to move forward without seeking revenge. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. And I want to thank you guys for listening. This episode was actually on YouTube. So it's not something I've talked about a lot. But, Yeah, we now do YouTube episodes if you want to go and I guess rewatch it. Probably not. But if you want to watch other episodes like this one, you can go to YouTube at The Psychology of
your 20s. You can also subscribe to us on Substack if you would like the transcript of this episode. It's free. I'll leave a link in the description. And also follow us on Instagram if you want to see behind the scenes or an episode breakdown or what we're planning for the next year or just want to keep in touch with the podcast. us at the best place to find us. But with all that said, with all that done, I'm going to close the episode by saying, thank you again for listening. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to
yourself. Don't always go after revenge. It might not be as satisfying as you think. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the...
the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so much. many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit
of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.